después de volver de españa este mes un
hombre de 33 años proveniente de hong
kong dio positivo para kobe 19 por
segunda vez cuatro meses y medio después
de haberse recuperado del primer
contagio una prueba genética mostró que
contrajo una cepa diferente del virus
convirtiéndose en la primera prueba de
una reinfección la facultad de medicina
de la universidad de hong kong dijo que
los resultados sugieren que la inmunidad
puede durar poco este virus es muy listo
porque sigue mutando
eso significa que aunque te hayas
recuperado de la infección
todavía necesitas vacunarse y utilizar
tapabocas huevos pero el caso de hong
kong no es el único dos pacientes uno en
países bajos y otro en bélgica también
se infectaron por segunda vez se trata
de un hombre mayor con un sistema inmune
débil y una mujer que se infectó por
primera vez en marzo y luego de nuevo en
junio
lo que hemos visto en estos casos es que
es tan diferente que no se trata del
mismo virus y múltiples estudios han
demostrado que la mayoría de personas
infectadas muestran una buena respuesta
inmune sin embargo algunos científicos
dicen que si las personas presentan
síntomas relativamente débiles el cuerpo
podría no crear suficientes anticuerpos
para prevenir una reinfección esperan
ver muchos más casos en los próximos
días